this morning former president trump says
it's okay to release the search warrant
and documents for the fbi search of his
mar-a-lago home trump says he encourages
a florida judge to approve attorney
general merrick garland's request to
make the warrant public the washington
post reports some of the classified
documents that were sought could be
related to nuclear weapons chief
election and campaign correspondent
robert costa joins us again bob good
morning did we expect the justice
department to do this good morning nate
attorney general merrick garland did
announce the motion to unseal the
warrant yesterday it was an
extraordinary move for the justice
department garland said he personally
approved the decision to seek a search
warrant cbs news has learned it was part
of an ongoing investigation into the
handling of sensitive records at trump's
florida estate earlier this year garland
also said the doj wants to publicize the
warrant in part because of the public
interest in what happened a report from
the washington post did state that the
documents believed to be at mar-a-lago
contain classified information and could
potentially fall into the wrong hands
one u.s official familiar with the
search told cbs news that the documents
related to nuclear material were part of
what agents were looking for
sources also told us that the former
president was issued a grand jury
subpoena for the documents in question
months before monday's search was
executed and throughout the week allies
of the former president have said he was
unfairly targeted by a politically
motivated justice department there has
been a spike in online threats against
the fbi since its search of mar-a-lago
and in ohio on thursday law enforcement
shot and killed an apparent trump
supporter who attempted to breach
security at an fbi field office while
armed with a gun
a gun and also a nail gun body armor
people in the area were told to shelter
and play stay in their homes as the
standoff continued do we know anything
more about that man in ohio bob what his
motivations might have been
tony we have cbs news has learned his
name was ricky schiffer a user that
appears to have been schiffer posted on
truth social one day after the search of
mar-a-lago issuing a call to arms and
writing in part quote this time we must
respond with force
additional posts that appear to be from
the same man claim he was at trump's
january sixth speech on the ellipse in
washington and at the capitol riot after
that
so returning to the question of the the
search warrant at the center of this
controversy before between the president
and the justice department
how significant would it be how unusual
would it be for this a warrant to be
unsealed and made public
for this warrant to be unsealed what
makes this request so unusual in this
moment so unusual is that it's
politically charged and it's it's
unlikely that the former president is
going to challenge it at this point uh
but and you see the former president
trying at this point to make a decision
to allow the bare bones aspect of this
to come forward
all right bob costa for us once again
bob thank you very much thank you